speak with confidence like these amazing
personalities every single one of these
amazing speakers have taken the same
program with brother Muhammad arshad
Muhammad arshad has helped develop all
of us it's extremely beneficial to do
this course definitely recommend this
course
so you was you came
right so but obviously using at fault
what made you come to Nation Islam and
then from there to come to actual Islam
right so so basically I'm from America
so I don't know if you see on the news
or whatever oh there's a lot of um
you know a lot of racism in America yeah
and um you know obviously those brothers
are still our brothers in humanity yes
um
um you know but it's it was very
appealing it's very appealing to us a
lot of black Americans we deal with
racism on a daily basis and you know the
idea of it is very appealing to young
black men and um so kind of just hearing
about the Oneness of God that made sense
uh hearing about um you know being
strong being men leaders in the
community that made sense
um but then there were some other things
that didn't make too much sense to me
you know um I believe if there is going
to be a god he's going to be the most
just he's not going to create people
who are less than others just for simply
being born yes
um so so you know luckily
um Allah guided me
um to some of the work that's done here
at Speaker's Corner Brothers like
yourself and uh other brothers on the
tower scene
um and I started hearing you you
Brothers you know giftawa and I don't
want you to think what you do here is is
my new or it's or it's not being heard
because if it wasn't for that situation
you know who knows where I'd be and and
kind of just listening to yes God is one
um but the prophet Muhammad is his it's
his final messenger you know no one came
after uh and and and and disappeared in
a spaceship and and you know
um so just just kind of hearing that
kind of gave me perspective and I've
also read certain books um uh it's like
before Malcolm X's for example
um the brother he he email I'll be
pleased with him he he joined the Nation
of Islam
um amongst that path as well and I'm not
sure if you're familiar he went to Mecca
yes yes and he saw he saw what is the
true Islam and um you know and and he
and when he came back to the USA that's
when his following his his purpose grew
even bigger because he was on their
straight path so I take that I take that
story I take that story uh to heart
um and uh yeah so basically yeah you
know so so what was the stuff Nation
Islam believed he said for example did
they did they say that what they think
about the white people
so um yeah I mean it's so they believe
that white people were created in a lab
um by uh by yaku
um okay at least that's what I was
taught
um and um and I I just couldn't believe
that you know um simply for the fact
that you know why would Allah create
humans and just because Allah is the
most merciful exactly so why so why
would he create human beings who are who
are at a
uh disadvantage I guess you could say
just by being born
negated Injustice to himself right and
and and it's and I just started
reflecting I look at all the other
creatures that Allah has created and
they have their purpose exactly they're
they're beautiful you know you could see
the mercy on Allah in Allah just by
taking a walk just in our hearts apart
yeah you know just you know so I I don't
believe that Allah will create something
to to to just curse it exactly just for
existing
um okay so where do you go from knowing
from Nation Islam that this is not
actually sound what were the things that
they believed that he was like hold on a
second this is not up yeah it was it was
definitely um white people being created
in a lab
um
got me to the straight path I had a nice
thick peanut butter and jelly sandwich
peanut butter smoothie you know um and
that's and that's not to disparage
anyone else's beliefs right but and a
lot of those Brothers the the crazy part
is Ali is a lot of those Brothers they
mean well but they're just you know in
America we go through a lot of pain
sometimes some of us and and you know
it's easy to to to get us to to that
point you know what I mean so and um but
yeah so I think it's very important also
they believe in profits after the
problem right right yes which is like a
father Muhammad who who they believe
um they actually pray facing Chicago
but but you know may Allah guide them
guide those friends
but why are they facing Chicago or
something it's uh his uh I'm not sure if
it's if if it's because his grave is
there
um I just I just I think that uh father
Muhammad who claims to be a prophet and
God himself I believe himself Allah and
no way yeah God himself and that uh he
let he actually left or he didn't die he
left Earth in a spaceship
but with an amazing wife and her with an
amazing husband may Allah give you guys
amazing children and really reunite you
guys in general I'm really happy to meet
you please see us more often in the UK
you lucky got this weather is
the pleasure meeting you
foreign